عميقه الخلافات بين الصين وبعض جيرانها
وامواجها عاتيه اكثر هذه الايام كل تقارب
بين بيجين وموسكو يزيد الهوت والتوتر في
المنطقه بعيون غير راضيه
دول الجوار المنوره الصينيه الروسيه في
بحر الصين الشرقي على سطح مياه المنطقه
تطفو ازمه قديمه جديده بشان ممرات مائيه
وجزر متنازع عليها ستدوم المناوره اسبوعا
وليست عاديه من حيث التوقيت والاهداف اصرت
موسكو على التوضيح وفق رئيسي اركان الجيش
الروسي فاليري هذا التعاون رد فعل طبيعي
على التراكم العدواني للامكانات العسكريه
الامريكيه في المنطقه مضيفا ان هدف
التدريبات المشتركه هو زياده قدره الجيشين
على مقاومه التحديات والتهديدات الجديده
مستنفره وتشعر بالتهديد مما يجري بالقرب
منها اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الطائرات الحربيه
الصينيه بتنفيذ استعراض للقوه فوق مضيق
تايوان خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه اضاف البيان ان 39 طائره حربيه
حلقت في اجواء جنوب غربي الجزيره بالاضافه
الى ثلاث سفن حربيه عبرت وسط مضيق تايوان
دخلت الفيليبين ايضا على خط المنزعجين من
تحركات التلميذ النائم اذ امرت مانيلا
جيشها بتعزيز وجوده في بحر الصين الجنوبي
السبب وفقها التهديد الذي تواجهه حاميه في
الممر المائي المتنازع عليه بسبب انشطه
صينيه غريبه ياتي هذا التطور بعد يومين
فقط من تقارير اعلاميه تحدثت عن السعاده
بيجين المزيد من الاراضي في ارخبيل
سبارتلي بدا من الصين النفس تلك الضرير
وايضا روايه مانيلا بشان استعاده حطام
صاروخ صيني لسفينه تابعه للبحريه
الفلبينيه قبله جزيره فيو كان حلف
المتوجين من الخطر الصيني في المنطقه
استنادا لخلافات قديمه وتقارير غربيه
كثيره منذ حرب اوكرانيا يتوسع اكثر هذه
الاونه قرروا طوكيو التاريخ قبل ايام
بتغيير سياستها الدفاعيه جزء من هذا
التحالف الذي لا ينضوي بالضروره تحت سن
واحد او مظله رسميه لم تخفي الحكومه
اليابانيه ان المراجعه الجذريه هي محاوله
للتصدي للنفذ العسكريه الصيني والمواجهه
تحدي نستراتيجي غير مسبوق لامن الارخبيل
ترياسه موسكو حليفه بدعه ايام قبل ان تدين
مساماتها عسكرت اليابان وجاء في بيان
الخارجيه الروسيه ان مثل هذا
التحركما تحديات امنيه ايه ده وسيؤدي الى
تصعيد التوتر في منطقتي اسيا والمحيط
الهادي له دوء على المديين القريب
والمتوسط بين معسكر الصين روسيا ومعسكر كل
من يستشعر التهديد منهما او احداهما ويميل
اكثر للحلف الغربي بقياده الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما بعد بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا لحدود له